is that something you would talk about
with anybody anymore
often it's in writing too you people
often I read that Edward R Murrow the
newscaster told a stranger on the plane
next to him and he had cancer and he'd
never told any of his family at that
point you know what I mean there's
something about telling strangers things
that's interesting it's like when you
write I'll often write things my 16 year
old daughter asked me something about my
past and Sam said to her if you want to
know Dad you should read his books
because I'll be much more forthcoming on
the page than I will be generally in
life with people even people I love and
I always think and I'm not the only one
lots of people talk about how that's the
case and I think that's really
interesting how we do that